my name is felina hermann and today i
will explain to you how to read
code specifically how to read very
confusing code and what
confusing code creates in your brain
what type of tension is created in your
brain
if you read confusing code before we
dive into the topic of
confusing code i actually want to take
you
back in into my own personal history to
explain to you
why i started to research complicated
code why i started to research
code reading and code comprehension the
process
of understanding code by people
this isn't because i i started that i
was a researcher already when i started
working on this but i was actually
working on other things
i wasn't working on code comprehension
but then
in the year 2013 what happened is
i started to teach kids at a community
center so i was already teaching at the
university
slightly older children adults of
student age
but in addition to that on saturdays i
started to teach in a programming club
for kids and these kids were like 8
9 10 year olds so so pretty young kids
and they asked me if i could
teach them programming so then i was
like yes
sure children no problem i can teach you
programming
even though i didn't really know that
much
about teaching i i of course knew how to
lecture i knew out at the university to
talk to a bunch of students
but that was really different from
teaching kids but
i didn't let that stop me i thought
i mean their kids they are eight or nine
year olds
how hard can it be right to teach them
programming
and then what happened is that
subconsciously
i started to think about how i learned
programming when i was a kid so this is
me
i am about 10 years old here sitting
behind my dad's computer
programming away that is how i
learned programming at a relatively
young age
but i didn't have a teacher there was no
one
teaching me programming i mainly learned
programming
from books i had this book basic
computer games and
maybe if you're the same age as i am you
might also have learned programming from
this type of books and in these books
there wasn't something like an
explanation it wasn't even very much a
tutorial or
a book that explained you something if
you open the book
this was what was inside just print it
out
basic listings that you could manually
copy into your computer
and then of course you made many
mistakes but you fixed all the mistakes
and then after a while
you had a program that's how i learned
programming
so again there wasn't someone teaching
me programming i more or less told
myself
and that's not just me many people my
age
children of the 80s so to say
all have learned or many have learned
programming in this way because
when we were kids there weren't so many
adults that
knew how to program and there was no
youtube so there weren't tutorials
either so
the best way at that time was just to
try stuff out
until it worked just let
kids explore let them figure out how to
do it by themselves
that vibe of self-exploration
is still very much present also if you
look at
programming books today so my strategy
in the programming club was
yeah you know let's buy a bunch of books
for kids just like i learned programming
from books
and i'll bring the books to the computer
club and the kids can learn from the
books
in those books you can clearly see that
they are written by people
that share my experience that came grew
up teaching themselves programming to a
certain extent
i have a few images from books here
the images will be in dutch but there's
always an english
translation underneath if you're not so
fluent in dutch which i could understand
so what do coding for kids books say for
example
the best part of programming is finding
mistakes
which is like a weird thing to say right
the best part of programming is finding
mistakes
i don't think so i i love programming
but
the best part is finding mistakes i mean
half of the time
i'm the person that puts in the mistakes
i don't really like finding mistakes
maybe fixing mistakes but finding
mistakes
yeah it's not really my favorite
programmers only learn from making
mistakes
that's also very much this perspective
of oh i figured it out
i tried a bit and then well there was a
mistake and i tried a bit more
but of course there are other things
that can result
from mistakes apart from learning some
kids if they make many mistakes maybe
they're just like you know
they will flip i don't care anymore
there are so many mistakes
i don't see a way out i don't think i
actually like this
as a hobby so this is clear survivorship
bias people that made many mistakes and
learned from them
they are now programmers writing these
books whereas
people that made many mistakes and they
thought wow this is super hard
they didn't grow up to become
programmers that later became
programming for kids authors
you will fail often and it will be
frustrating
beware children this is also
special right of course it is true of
course if you learn programming if you
learn
anything you will fail often and it will
be frustrating
but why do we tell kids this
right compare this to a book about
learning learning to play soccer for
example
this will have nice pictures of famous
soccer players
and probably it will say something like
well soccer
maybe it's hard but if you practice a
lot you too can be a professional soccer
player
certainly it will say soccer is hard
and it will be frustrating it will
actually encourage
trying but it will not stress the
difficulty this is
a very programming specific thing to say
where as a community
we sort of like that it's hard right we
like that our profession is difficult
and that it isn't
for everyone maybe here's another one
never be afraid to mess around and
experiment break the rules
so i think you know breaking the rules
is pretty good solid life advice i like
to break the rules now and then
but breaking the rules in programming
like does that make sense as an advice
this book computer coding for kids
is about a programming language called
python
that i guess many of people that are
viewing today are familiar with
so python like most programming
languages
has a bunch of rules that you cannot
break this is a page in the same book
so this says a colon goes there a
quotation mark goes there
a rectangular bracket goes there not a
round bracket
not a curly bracket no it has to be a
rectangular bracket
those are rules you cannot break so the
advice about rule breaking
is very much the perspective of someone
that has already
ascended to expert level someone that
has already broken
what we call the syntax barrier someone
that can see through syntax
and that isn't is no longer bordered by
small mistakes
but of course if you're a beginner like
what is the difference between a round
bracket and a rectangular bracket
and why is that a rule i cannot break
what rules
should i break this also is advice that
very much
fits the survivor bias of someone who is
now an expert
projecting on children and most
importantly
it's fun most importantly
so so notice what this doesn't say right
it doesn't say programming is a really
good career and it can easily make you a
solid living
or programming is a means of expression
it's a very creative thing to do and
you can build whatever you want no none
of them
the most important thing is that it's
fun
which again is a perspective of someone
who has enjoyed
learning and especially the combination
with
this is hard and this is frustrating but
also you have to like it
and also there are magic rules you
cannot break but break a few other rules
it's all not very helpful as advice as
a community we are projecting sort of
weird things on
kids that want to learn programming
and as i said this is a perspective not
just shared by me
what you see here are the results of a
survey on the website stack overflow
that i guess
most people listening today are familiar
with
this survey was done among 90 000
programmers
so a pretty solid sample of programmers
in the workforce today
what you can see here is that 85
of programmers in the workforce today
learned programming before the age of
19. so before they were
in university before they were adults
and a big
part of that 85 percent will to a
certain extent be
self-taught learners because many
countries
don't really have programming at the
high school
or middle school level so a big chunk of
people in the workforce today
also learned programming alone by
themselves to a certain extent
being self-taught and this leads to a
culture in which people that teach
programming very often let kids explore
that's very much how i started to teach
when i started to teach programming to
kids just let them explore
here's a bunch of books i turn on the
computers
if you make a mistake the computer will
tell you
basically the teaching philosophy that i
had there and that
many people have is the compiler is the
teacher
if you make a mistake you get an error
message it tells you what to do
a teacher might not be although that
necessary
of course we don't say that like
literally allowed
but that's the culture that underlies
many of
those programming lessons certainly it
did underlie my programming lesson
then surprisingly especially to people
that actually know about teaching
kids were like wow that is really hard
we tried something but
you know we still don't know how to do
it kids would ask me the same question
every week they'll be like okay i want
to have an extra level in my game how do
i do this and i'll be like
well this this this try it
and then the next week the same kid
would be like
okay but how do i add an extra level
and i was like well i explained this to
you last week
how do you not remember and i really
didn't understand
why they couldn't remember i didn't
understand that
saying something like the fact that this
knowledge has exited my mouth
didn't mean that it even entered their
ears let alone
entered their memories so at this point
i also became like sad and frustrated
and at that point also my my scientific
curiosity kicked in because as i said i
was a scientific researcher at that
point i just
wasn't researching programming for kids
i was actually researching professional
programmers at that point
but then i thought someone must have
looked into this
and indeed they had i found this paper
called skill progression
demonstrated by users in scratch where
scratch is a programming language
specifically made for kids
and this paper found that many kids
start to program
and then stop programming so there's a
really high
dropouts and this was a study that only
looked at data
so we don't there were no interviews so
we don't really know why the kids
dropped out
but maybe it had something to do with
programming being really hard and
frustrating
and you should enjoy that otherwise
you're just not made for it
what this paper also found is that
children after a while
flattened their skill level so initially
kids learn quite a bit
but then after a while their skill level
drops
they don't acquire new knowledge
anymore and that also really fitted with
what i saw in the programming club that
initially of course they learned a bit
and then they didn't advance and i
didn't understand
why fast forward a little bit
to 2020 last year a paper came out
that is called if they build it will
they
understand it and this paper basically
says
well the answer is no if kids build
something
in a programming language that doesn't
mean that they
understand it so these people actually
did a study
in which kids were observed not just
their data was analyzed
and they looked at if a child makes a
program with for example a variable in
it
if you later quiz them give them a test
on variables
the fact that it occurs in their program
does that mean that they can
correctly answer quiz questions on a
topic like
loops or variables and the answer was no
so very often kids can use a variable in
a program
but they don't really understand it
probably they came to the solution
by looking what their next door neighbor
was doing
or looking on youtube or just trying out
many times so just the fact that a kid
can
do something doesn't mean that they
really grasp concepts
which also fit it with what what i saw
at the
pyramid club that kids were doing stuff
like they were making
games and they were sort of happy but
they would ask the same question
every week they weren't learning even
though they were sometimes having fun
and they were
making programs so
back to 2013 i didn't know
most of that at the time i just knew
that
the kids were learning and i didn't know
why
and again i didn't really know that much
about learning
and you might think well wait a minute
didn't you just say you're a professor
that you were teaching in a university
well yes but in the netherlands and also
in many other countries around the world
we have this fantastic system
where if you want to teach elementary
school you go to school for four years
if you want to teach in high school you
go to school for five years
but if you want to teach at a university
you just get a phd in any topic
like astrophysics or software
engineering like i did
and then 12 afternoons of educational
training
and then you are good to go to teach
so technically i was teaching qualifies
but that didn't really mean that i had a
working understanding
of how to teach specifically
on how to do anything else than just
say stuff and hope that it magically
stuck to children's or students brains
but at that point i started to get
really really
interested in learning specifically
because the kids in the programming club
were struggling so much
clearly my undergrads at that time were
also struggling because i just wasn't
doing such a great job in teaching
but the nice nice thing about an
eight-year-old that is confused is
they will tell you like one of the kids
in my club
and one day came to me after class and
he looked me in the eye and he said
i am not coming back to this stupid
programming club
and i was like oh you know right in the
fields
what what are you saying but
he he was right i mean he wasn't
learning anything
but that really hurt well not just
because it hurt but also
because i thought to myself if i can get
an eight-year-old that voluntarily comes
to a community center on saturday
to learn programming to learn
programming
this is on me like it's not because he's
not motivated he isn't willing to put in
the work
he's showing up and i am failing him so
then i was like
man i have to get better at this
so that brought me to start to research
how people learn how do people learn
anything like i had no clue
so i started to really deep dive into
how people learn
things and specifically how people
acquire languages how people acquire
their first
natural language so one of the things i
read which i can really recommend
if you want to read about how people
learn to read
is the oxford handbook of reading which
it does stretch the definition of a
handbook a bit it is like 600 pages
but it has so much information about how
kids learn
their first natural language and the
first thing i learned from this book
is we never teach reading code
we never teach how to read code
this just isn't a thing that comes up
not in universities not
in programming clubs for kids not in
boot camps for adults that want to
go into coding it's just not a thing we
explain
like i had kids in class that were like
hey teacher i made this program in
scratch
last week but i don't really remember
like how it works
can you help me what does this do
and then i would be like well child
what do you think it does
and this was very much the sculpture of
never be afraid
to mess around and experiment i almost
literally said to the kid
well kid don't be afraid to mess around
and experiment just try it out
but i didn't in any way help
them to read the program and if you
compare that to reading natural language
if
your kid goes to school we don't say
hey children in in grade one here's the
alphabet
now here's a book no even they practice
all the time it's like
book we teach them strategies as well we
teach them
strategies for how to read words
in the netherlands when we teach this
usually we use this
motion so kids are taught with every
letter to use this motion and then to
glue the letters together
we teach them tricks that help them read
but then for this program how
would you even read this so this is
scratch a visual language
and all these scripts are ran in
parallel
and this is it's event based so maybe if
you can read them
depending on your screen if you can read
what the code says
they're events so when up arrow is
pressed
when i receive a certain um message
when down arrow is pressed and when i
receive another message so all these
scripts are sort of
running at the same time in something
like a game loop
and when an event happens they are
turned on so to say
so how would you read this code it's not
even like
imperative python code that you could
read top to bottom
it's not even an easy question to answer
from me as a professional
how you would read this and we never
gave kids
any strategies on how to read this and
then of course the kid was like i don't
know
it's like what do you think the kids i
don't know you never
explained anything to me about how to do
this
clearly i don't know and again compare
this to
reading your first natural language
imagine you have a
five six seven year old at home and
you're like
mommy what's that word you probably
don't say
well honey what do you think it says
that is that's not helpful you probably
help them break down the problem like
maybe you point that the first letter
you're like that first letter do you
recognize it
it's the first letter of your little
brother's name you know he's called
albert
it's also do you recognize the letter
and then the kid is like oh yeah maybe
that's an
a so you ask them to know the first
letter
or maybe you look at clues
in the vicinity where does it say apple
maybe you're in the supermarket and it's
next to
the apples so you can also teach them
hey maybe you want to
look at the context what could this mean
based on what you see but you would help
them figure it out
you wouldn't just say oh what's that but
then the cat the kid might say
cat dinosaur i have no clue
and this isn't just teaching in school
so you might think well now you're
comparing programming
very often outside of school with things
we teach in schools like reading
but it isn't just reading it's also
music for example
if your kid wants to play a musical
instrument the teacher also doesn't say
well here's a guitar
just try you know try whatever works for
you
oh do you want to learn tennis well
here's a tennis racket and two balls
just make up some rules
for all of those things we break up the
problem
in small steps and we practice the small
steps
in tennis you might want to practice the
backhand and the forehand
and the surface and in guitar playing
you might want to play the note c
100 times until you get your fingers
correctly
and only then you move on
so from all these perspectives both
inside of schools and outside of schools
practicing small skills is the key to
getting better
and then we never practice the skill of
reading code that was
weird when i started to dive into
reading i didn't understand why we don't
teach that
explicitly and this really isn't
exclusively an issue to children
i i'm still also teaching undergrads and
i have had
second or third year students that
needed to read a piece
of python that that they handed in or
that one of their teammates handed in
it's like okay what does this code do
where is the error they would literally
start at the top of the
file and just read all the lines
and then at first i'd be like you know
that is not very smart
why would you do that why wouldn't you
just follow the call stack
but then i realized i had never taught
them
to follow the call stack i don't
remember how i picked up that that was a
good strategy
but no one told me to do that
so clearly there's a bunch of people
that can learn it on their own
but there's so many more people that
could also learn it if we would just
tell them so we don't teach reading code
and that's really something that
now i'm working on of course now that
i'm teaching children and undergrads
in the proper way certainly now i'm
teaching them how to read code
that's actually what we will be talking
about a little bit later on in this
stream as well
what i also found from studying what
people do
in other fields is that not just we
don't teach reading
as teachers but also as professionals
we never practice reading if you want to
be a good guitar player
you don't stop to practice small things
after you had guitar lessons you will
continuously
always hone your skills you will still
do
cd efg before every show even if you are
professional
so we don't really practice reading
whereas
research shows that code reading is very
important
for our practice this paper baxia at
all shows that professional programmers
spend
58 percent of their time reading code
so almost 60 percent of the time you
professional programmer in the audience
are reading code yet when you practice
to read code
never we always think
that if you want to get better at
programming you should do more
programming
advancing in programming is writing more
programs
and we really like to celebrate saturday
night open source projects oh you need
to
have a hobby project to be a good
programmer
some people go as far as to say that if
you don't have a hobie project
you're not a proper programmer we always
think
that if you want to get better at
programming you should program more
never be afraid to mess around and
experiment right
try out stuff that's important
maybe recently two months back it was
december
people were participating in advent of
code which is fun like i love advent of
code
but it does show that we do see getting
better
as writing more it wasn't an advantage
of reading code
it wasn't like oh every day of december
we will give you a code snippet and you
just have to figure out what it says
no it is here's a prompt and you write
code which is
much of how i spent my undergrad days
was
here's a problem like reverse a linked
list and write
code and how i told as well and i think
how many people were told
very much with a focus on writing code
as a means to get better at programming
so we don't really
practice code reading either and then
the third thing that i learned from
looking at how other fields have their
stuff together
is that we don't really have theories
for reading code
like what happens in your brain if you
read code i don't know
but i also at this point didn't know
that other people do
know but fields like natural language
actually have a pretty solid
understanding of how
how your brain processes text processes
words i was like wow that's so cool i
didn't know
you could even know that so that's what
i want to talk about
in like the rest of the half hour we
have today
is what happens in your brain when you
read code
and what do we already know from what
happens in your brain when you read
text that we can use we don't have to
reinvent the wheel
people know this and we can just use
what natural language already knows
so what what do we know about code
reading or about reading
language when information enters your
brain it first enters the short
term memory that i guess you have heard
of
so firstly information is stored in your
short-term memory
for a brief period of time you can think
a bit of this
as your brain's ram information can be
stored there
briefly and it's a lot smaller than
long-term storage
and this has been known for a pretty
long time already
so george miller in the 1950s already
said
that your short-term memory is really
small
it can only hold between five and nine
elements so it's really really tiny
let's actually try that in practice so i
hope you are
participating looking at the chat as
well in the meantime i hope you are
participating
i will show you a brief sentence just a
sentence of three words
and it is your job at home to remember
and reproduce
the sentence but i will show it to you
for a very brief time it's like half a
second it'll be like
and it's gone just to show you how
bad how small your short term memory is
so i hope you're watching at home there
we go prepare
so i guess you're screaming at your
phone like this is unreasonably hard
harmons
this is undoable we cannot do it
well i'm sorry that's just how small
your short term memory is
it can only hold between five and nine
elements actually newer research even
suggest
it might be smaller it might be between
two and
six elements in any case it is really
really small
so now you might wonder well
if our short term memory is so small how
do we do anything
like how is it possible that i can speak
in a language that isn't even my first
language
and also wave my hands and also
occasionally
look at the chat messages how is that
even possible with such a tiny brain
well your short-term memory doesn't work
alone
it actually collaborates in your brain
with your working memory
so if you have read a sentence then
from the term memory it is sent on
processed through the working memory
but in the working memory not just
information from your short term memory
is stored
but also information from your long-term
memory
your long-term memory really helps
your working memory process and of that
we will also see a small example
so i'll show you yet another sentence
and there you can see that your
short-term memory
can be supported by your long-term
memory
here we go i hope you're ready for yet
another sentence
so that felt doable i guess right
it was still hard i know it was still
quite hard
but at least now you could make sense of
what was there
probably you could understand a few
letters
not because it was substantially like
inherently easier
but those letters are things you've
practiced
so often you've looked at letters
that you can very quickly recognize
and remember that and i will show you
even how
your long-term memory can support your
short-term memory
so that you can remember a sentence
something that seemed undoable just a
few minutes ago
certainly turns out to be relatively
easy
if your long-term memory helps you so
i'll show you a third sentence and i am
sure
everyone can do it if you just like
don't blink
and don't miss the sentence you can
remember this like 100 here we go
so that was easy right even though it
was
the exact same length of the first
sentence and the second sentence
but what happens here is you can quickly
understand this remember this why
because you're not remembering half a
circle
and a circle with a coma attached to it
and a catholic cross and a long stripe
and a
tiny circle you're not remembering like
that
you can immediately recognize the
letters because you've seen them so
often
and then not only are you recognizing
the letters
you are recognizing words you are saying
not in your memory c a t l o v
e no it's like cat it's one thing so
those
things are retrieved from your long term
memory
you know the letters you know what a
cake is and what laws is
so the number of things you have to
remember now
has suddenly decreased from all the
individual letters which are
way too many to three things
which easily fit your short-term memory
so here you see in action the
collaboration between
long and short term memory
so now let's let's circle back to
programming because it sort of turned
into
an introductory cognitive science
lecture which is also
interesting i guess but i know most of
you came here to listen
to know about getting better at reading
code what happens in your brain
when you read code so let's look at
three
different programs because with the
different
forms of memory short-term memory
long-term memory and working memory come
different processes related to code
different reasons why code can be
confusing
so let's look at this program it's a
program in a programming language called
apl which is sort of a weird and
esoteric programming language that most
most professional programmers don't know
it's very old it's from like 1960
and it's mainly meant to do vector
calculations
so i'm just gonna assume that this
program to you is confusing
because the program is 2 2 2 2 2
t n like this is the program
this is an entire program in apl
so why are you confused by this
it's because of the t you don't know
what
t does you probably know what to do to
do
you know that it's twos and i will tell
you that the n
is the input parameter to this program
so you know what that is
it will be a number as well but then
what is that
t thing
so this is an issue with your long term
memory right you just don't know what
the t
is it's not because you're not capable
of processing this program
you just don't know what the thing is no
one ever told you what it is
so you have a long-term memory issue
this program a java program
also might be confusing to you
especially if you're not a trained
java programmer if you're like me mainly
using python
as a programming language then this
might be confusing because it
overloads your short-term memory
if you really want to understand it you
have to remember many things
public class binary calculator public
static void
main end and system output line into
your binary string
if you're an experienced java programmer
you probably know that
public clause and public static void
main it's all not so important
probably where the importance are is in
the binary string in binary
calculation but you can only see that if
you're not all too confused by all the
fluff that is there so this program is a
bit
fluffy and if you're not used to it this
will be
heavy on your short term memory
here is a third program by the way they
all do the same
all these programs calculate the binary
representation
of the number n here's a program
that's also confusing probably but it's
confusing for
yet another reason here the program is
confusing
because you have to do so many things it
is your working memory
in this program that is being
stressed is being being stretched to its
limits
because what is going on here you can't
really see
probably if you would actually have to
debug this program you would take
a pen you'd say okay well let's just try
this for the value n
okay so n is seven what happens okay so
b is the empty string
and then this loop goes from seven
to zero okay so then n
is okay that's seven divided by two so
that's
three because it's rounded okay uh so
then b
string is okay so it's a string zero
okay
what happens in the next iteration so
you just have to
work really hard to understand this
if you're somewhat familiar with with
programming languages even if you're not
familiar with basic
you will know what most of this does you
know let you know the equal sign
assignment you know the empty string you
know a for loop
your your long term memory is fine
right the issue here is your working
memory
you have to do so many things
so you might be like yes but what you've
just showed us
just means that reading code is really
hard
look you showed us all these types of
confusing confusion
and that might lead to what i something
sometimes think is so sad that people
they look at
a certain library like i sometimes do
this oh i need a partial library in
python let me go on github
and then you look at code that someone
else has written
and you look at it you're like yeah this
is so hard to read
it's probably easier if i just write my
own parser framework
which i think very often is not really
true
but we think it's true because we have
practiced
writing so much that's where our fluency
is
but we've never really practiced reading
we don't really have
theories for reading so of course it is
hard
if i ask non-trained people to do a
marathon tomorrow
they'd be like that is super hard
because i never
did a marathon but a marathon isn't
inherently hard right i know if you've
never ran a marathon that probably
sounds like
terrible to you but it isn't inherently
hard i mean
you can already walk it's just you do
that many many times
it's only hard if you've never practiced
if you if you practice a lot doing a
marathon is not so bad
actually and it's sort of the same with
code where
we're dreaming code where it sounds
terrible but that's because you never
practice
but you could practice you can actually
get a lot
better at code reading if you would just
practice
so here's a few things that you can do
what i
hope that you do after watching this
video
the next time that you actually
encounter
code that is hard to read i hope that
you will reflect
and you will think okay so that was
uncomfortable
is this a long-term memory issue is it
just
really hard because i don't know syntax
is this a short-term memory issue
is this just really hard because i have
to remember many things and i don't yet
know
what is and what isn't important
or is this a working memory issue where
like okay i think i can oversee
all the syntax elements and all the
elements that play a role
but i don't know how they interact with
each other
these three different problems have
different
solutions so if your problem is i don't
know this syntax
then you can learn you could practice
syntax i know it's not really a thing we
do
but it works just really really well
so you can make a stack of cards called
flash cards
where on one hand side you put the
the prompt so you for example in the apl
example
you could put on one side the t which
actually isn't d
it's called encode and then on the other
side of the card you say encode
and this is how you could learn all the
apl keywords that are all
operators but of course this doesn't
have to be apl it can also be python
where you say
for loop on one hand side and then the
syntax of the for loop on the other side
or if there's a certain um a certain api
that you want to learn
retrieve a file and then what what you
have to do is on the other side of the
card
if you practice that you'll get a bigger
vocabulary
of syntax so then you're less likely to
have these long-term memory issues
if you have working memory issues on the
other hand
if it's very very hard to process the
individual elements
of code and how they interact with each
other
you can support your working memory your
working memory is
basically it's your short-term memory
applied to a certain problem
so it also has this very small size
limitation
but you could help it for example
something you could do
is you could have a tracing table like
you see here
where you step by step analyze what's
going on
so you say okay in the initialization
and the 7 and 2 is 7 very systematically
b string is the empty string and n one
is also seven and then
step by step okay loop iteration one
this is what happens
iteration two this is what happens and
you can do this manually as you see me
do here
but clearly of course this can also be
done supported by an ide
where you really systematically step
through the code
to try to gain an understanding and make
it
easier for your working memory to
understand because you offload the
important information
somewhere and this could be on a literal
piece of paper or
you can put all of this as watches on
variables in your ide but at least
you're offloading some of your working
memory elsewhere
so that you could process code more
easily
so that is the good news you can get
better at
reading code firstly by self reflecting
and understanding
what type of confusion are we dealing
with
what you can also do as a really really
nice technique to remember code
is sorry to diagnose code reading skills
is to remember code
so if i show this code to you for a
little bit
just well maybe not half a second as i
did with the sentences but
three minutes for example and then i
take the code away
and now i would ask you reproduce that
code as best as you can
if you do that you'll get a really nice
insight into what you know
because some of these parts like the
highlighted parts here
come from your long-term memory probably
public class blood static void main
you didn't really remember that you just
remembered
define a class and define a main method
and then later on you use your long-term
memory to reproduce the exact syntax
because you already know it
whereas some things in this program
highlighted here in green come from your
short-term memory
remembering that this was in search and
sort remembering that this
variable was called array and the values
in it were 45
and 12 etc that is all coming from your
short term memory and then it comes
together
and actually at this time little
marketing for my research
we are exploring this so if you're just
interested in helping science
figure it out you can go to felina.com
test where we have a little memory
exercise in java
for you you don't have to do this right
now by the way because the url will also
be at the end
of the presentation so you don't have to
leave the stream and go straight there
you can do this later on as well
what you can also do as a great aid in
getting better at
reading code is to force yourself to
summarize code
for example look at code for 10 minutes
just a number depends a bit on the size
as well of course
and then force yourself to write down
what was the goal
of this course sorry of this code what
are the most
important lines here what were the
decisions that were made
what were the relevant concepts here
what are the things that really play a
role
both the domain concepts and also the
programming content
you might recognize this as an exercise
if you have
kids in high school or if you well
remember your high school days
you might recognize this as an exercise
that is commonly given
in natural language class in english
class kids would read
newspaper articles all the time in high
school
and would be asked the exact same thing
hey
here's a newspaper article summarize
this in three lines
this is like always on the sats in the
netherlands
there is a question where you have to
summarize
text in a few lines because we know
those are strategies that help you read
natural language
being able to quickly summarize
something being able
to quickly find what are the five most
important lines of code here
and that's not something you just
magically pick up
those are skills you can also train so
if you want to get
better at coding in addition to
understanding like why is this confusing
deliberately
practicing reading code for example by
summarizing
is a really good technique so if you
want to know more about this
i just gave you like the taster of how
knowing your brain's architecture can
help you to become a better code reader
and this
a better programmer definitely want to
check out my book
the programmer's brain on manning and
you're in luck because tomorrow
the book will be the deal of the day so
definitely
be sure to follow me on twitter i'm at
felina of course follow manning on
twitter as well
so you can get a discount if you buy the
book tomorrow and i think there's also
yes there's also some chat messages here
by manning
that will also link to where you can buy
the book
what you can also do as an alternative
or
an addition is start a code
reading club so many professionals that
i've worked with over the last
year and a bit have started to gain an
interest in getting better at code
reading
and there are ways that you could
practice this
as a group and we started to call that a
code reading club
where weekly or monthly you just get
together with a few colleagues
you take a piece of code from github or
from your own repo
doesn't really matter and you just
practice to systematically
read a piece of code it is a bit like
like a book club
where you all read the same book and
then you chat about it it is really like
a book club
but then it's about code and you pick
the code together
we found that that is really a really
great way
to practice this skill of coding of code
reading
but also just a nice way to hang out
with colleagues because
you know it's covet time so there's not
a lot of social stuff going on
but this is also a nice way to interact
with colleagues that isn't
really about work it's sort of enjoyable
but also it's very
useful we have a link also at the end of
the
talk so that's it that's
everything i wanted to share from you
with you
today of course there's still room for
questions so if you want to ask me
anything please put your questions in
the chat before we go
to answer me answering the questions in
the chat let me
summarize my entire talk in like two
minutes because
i know i talk a bit quickly i
try to make it better but it's just it's
just how i talk i'm sorry so
to compensate i have a little summary
for you
so in summary i have talked about how to
read code my name is felina i'm at
felina on twitter if you want to follow
me
programming comes from a culture in
which we very much
think that
by programming you get better at
programming and that sort of programming
is the only way to get pre better at
programming
that culture is very visible also from
the way we teach children
but research has shown that just by
programming you don't necessarily really
understand
what you're doing some kids might but
definitely
not all kids will if you want to be more
systematic about getting better at
programming
you have to know a little bit about
how your brain processes processes
things
and what you saw in a little experiment
that we did with the three sentences
is that what your long-term memory
knows really helps how quickly you can
process something
if you are looking at things you've
never seen before
like apl or that weird alphabet that i
invented
it's very hard to even process something
whereas if you recognize some of the
elements
it gets spectacularly easy
these different forms of memory create
different forms of confusion if you
don't know a lot of syntax you might
want to practice syntax
deliberately if your working memory is
overloaded by complex code
you might want to support your working
memory
by offloading some of your thinking to
paper or to your ide
there are many techniques from a reading
that you could use for example
summarizing code is a very effective way
to just deliberately practice reading
like as i said in music we practice
notes like in tennis you practice your
backhand
and your forehand practicing those small
skills
this is not rocket science like everyone
does this
math and language and sports and music
it's just time that programming also
starts to do that remembering code is
also a really great
way to practice and also diagnose
your own skill because as you as you've
also seen with the three examples
the more you remember the more you
already know
so as a way of diagnosing what you
remembering codes can be really helpful
so that's the end i will look at the
chat after i
finished these final slides again my
name is felina hermans i'm on twitter
at felina if you want to check out my
website my website
very easy just my first name felina.com
if you want to know more about the book
that has chapters and chapters
of more and deeper explanation about how
your cognitive architecture works
and how that matters for programming
whole chapters on
picking the best variable names for
comprehension
refactoring your code so that is easier
to read
all of that felina.com book
that will bring you to the manning page
where you can
buy the ebook straight and start reading
straight away
or pre-order the print book that is
coming out in spring
2021. um
if you're interested in listening to me
and you really like listening to me so
far
then you can listen to me a bit more for
free i'm also one of the hosts of
software engineering radio
one of the biggest software engineering
podcasts on the web we are on spotify
and itunes
in an interview format where me and
other hosts interview
famous software engineers and every week
a show comes out
if you want to help our research if you
go to felina.com
test you can participate in a little
test it only takes you like a few
minutes
to remember code and reproduce java code
and it will really help support my
resource so if that's
what you want to contribute to we'd be
really happy if you would be interested
in doing that
if you want to know more about starting
a code club we have
free resources felini.com club
it's all free you don't have to buy
anything you can just get started with a
starting package of
exercises that we put on github so
that's
everything i wanted to share with you
today let's just look at if there are
questions
in the chat awesome people say oh code
reading club is such a good idea i never
thought about it
that's no problem you can think about it
now and start straight away if you just
find a few colleagues like two or three
colleagues
can already found a club together and
and i promise you
it will really really be helpful and be
a fun way also
to interact with your colleagues cool
well thanks people also
that are seeing in the chat that they
will check out the book of course i'm
really happy
you can start reading for free just to
check out if you like the book before
you buy it
and again all my contact information is
on the slide so if you want to
ask me questions if you want to reach
out to me feel free to do so on twitter
or over email
my contact information on email is also
on my website